I died some say it was only for eight
seconds but I know it was more than that
hey youtubers it's Charlie this week
agents of shield was Whedon classic it
was all about character development and
relationships while at the same time
crossing paths with the Avengers that's
right just because you cross passes the
two hundred million dollar movie doesn't
mean you can't care about your
characters so let's talk about our
favorite moments and then I'll do my
review so the monster of the week was
actually a re virus leftover from
the Avengers invasion while that in and
of itself was not super interesting the
side effects so the symptoms were really
interesting instead of bleeding out of
your skull you give off this electric
pulse that makes your brain look like a
burp potato my number one favorite part
of the episode though was getting this
really intimate look at Fitz and Simmons
characters typically they've kind of
been sidelined in a lot of the previous
episodes but this was their episode it
was also a big episode for Agent Coulson
in May so if you were a shipper this is
the episode for you the episode and the
soundtrack consequently did this amazing
job of building tension all the way up
into the moment where Elizabeth
Henstridge jumped off the back of the
plane she basically had to carry the
last half of this episode and I thought
she did a great job
to be fair I actually kind of thought
that she was gonna be saved by some sort
of pulse or a smaller version of the
pulse that was killing everyone but it
ended up being Ward jumping out of the
back of the plane to save her there were
actually a lot of awesome buried Thor
references in Ward's character in this
episode he's basically like the Thor
character trying to punch all of his
problems away but if you remember in one
of the Thor trailers Loki actually says
to Thor you can't solve all your
problems by hitting that's basically
where Ward was in this episode and he
was able to save Simmons by jumping out
of the back of a plane in the end but
really it was on Fitz and Simmons
character to find the solution to this
problem my number-two favorite thing in
the episode was Coulson in May
not only are they totally an implied
couple we also got some more answers
about Coulson's death but based on the
fact that he has that scar I'm guessing
that whatever was done to his body to
bring him back he's still in that body
it's still his original body so that
kind of negates life model decoy theory
but it still kind of supports the idea
of using magic or some sort of Asgardian
medical technology to save him but what
did I think of the episode overall this
is actually my favorite episode so far
it was so classic Whedon it's all about
building relationships between the
characters that you can really believe
and building a relationship between me
in the characters that I really believe
in personally I did
really care about the Avengers
references I mean they were cool it's
fun to see that stuff but I didn't care
about any of the tech or the solutions
to the problem it was really about the
emotional journey these characters were
on and that is why Joss Whedon gets to
direct things like The Avengers because
he can make you care about the
characters and just forget about all the
tech even though there's a lot of fun to
watch but let me know what your favorite
moments were and did this episode change
the way you think about any of the
characters on the show particularly
Elizabeth Henstridge there's actually
some really cool stuff coming from
agents of shield in the next couple of
weeks
be sure to subscribe to get all my
videos next week we actually get to find
out what comes after level seven and
then two weeks after that we actually
get an episode that's directed by
Commander Riker from Star Trek The Next
Generation
that's an episode that's going to cross
paths with Thor of the dark world the
stories are gonna work together so it's
gonna be a really really cool in other
news I'm posting my new supernatural
video tomorrow morning be sure to check
back for that I also have a Star Wars
Episode 7 video that I might post
tomorrow - we just found out some
information on the casting of the main
characters right now learn more about
agents of shield this season by clicking
here and click here to learn more about
Star Wars Episode 7 thank you so much
for watching see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you